[Musique]
jetons
aujourd'hui c'est une journée un peu
particulière c'est je crois la première
fois que je fais une vidéo que je me
prépare absolument rien écrire le script
orient je décris rien rien de chez rien
aujourd'hui c'est une journée très
exceptionnel très particulière parce que
j'ai reçu ce paquet la main si vous êtes
au courant il ya quelque temps j'ai
passé les 100 milles à bout d'un an là
on est plus proche des 200 milles que
des 102 millions qu'on devait être
aujourd'hui sur un chêne 188 me sens 89
milles ce qui est énorme
je vous en remercie dû taper fort parce
que j'ai un micro mais du plus profond
de mon coeur parce que c'est un truc
assez dingue en fait le parcours de
youtube mais avant de vous parler de ça
séquence émotion s'est pas ouvert
voulait vraiment l'ouvrir avec vous
partager ce moment et on va rester en
plan fixe comme sa caméra je pas faire
de gros plans et où je vois là pour
partager ce que je peux ressentir ça y
croyez moi c'est vraiment un truc assez
direct parce que en fait c'est un je
sais pas si vous avez une chaîne youtube
je suppose que vous regardez d'autres
créateurs mais si vous avez une scène
youtube vous savez que c'est un parcours
qui est parsemé d'embûches quel que soit
votre nombre d'abonnés on s'en fiche
c'est pas important
alors effectivement arrivé à un certain
niveau on pas en vivre mais même si on
est ainsi l'appel des petits créateurs
et qui ne peuvent pas en vivre ah c'est
pas important
après je peux comprendre que ça
s'appelle frustrant mais c'est pas la
question
donc si vous êtes créateur vous savez le
travail que ça représente
l'investissement l'envi la passion
derrière et certaines fois les
frustrations
parce que c'est un chemin c'est un
chemin non seulement c'est un chemin
c'est un chemin qui est semé d'embûches
et non pas demain qu'ils échouent mais
d'embûches
c'est donc un chemin qui est semé
d'embûches c'est où et c'est assez dur
et c'est à la fois passionnant c'est à
la fois hyper intense quand on s'y met à
fond c'est un truc qui est vachement
génial et quand on a la chance de
pouvoir progresser d'avoir une
communauté qui vous suit et de plus en
plus nombreuses ce qui est mon cas je
vous en remercie énormément
et bien c'est hyper cool et le fait
d'arriver aujourd'hui avec des petits
paquets trophée pour naissant mille
abonnés même si effectivement les cent
mille abonnés sont passés depuis le 20
novembre
croyez moi je suis là j'attendais
vraiment avec impatience et j'ai pu la
voir depuis peu ça a pris un temps fou
donc bon mais voilà il est là il est
beau il est chaud et
c'est vraiment un moment très important
dans la vie d'un créateur youtube tout
simplement parce que ben voilà ce
trophée des 100000 j'en rêvais depuis
que depuis que j'ai commencé en sachant
que de façon je me suis dit départ ils
vont même pas comment je peux réussir à
ce que cent mille personnes elles
s'inscrivent à machel donc ça me
semblait complètement impossible est
réalisable mais le fait est que ce
trophée là et que on ne l'a pas envoyé
par hasard et que du coup bah c'est que
ça marche et que le travail paye que la
passion quand on essaie de tout faire
partager sa passion
eh bien ça ça paye quoi ça peut payer et
ça c'est une juste une des plus belle
récompense la plus belle c'est
effectivement que vous soyez présents
aujourd'hui que j'ai la possibilité de
faire ça a plus que temps complet c'est
le cas de le dire mais ça en tout cas ça
fait partie vraiment de vocation et
c'est vraiment chouette
alors on se louvre ensemble aller vivre
en me disant waouh papier polystyrène je
sais pas te voir ces trucs en plus hier
cette anecdote j'étais à la garden party
de la do you tube et la hesse a cédé on
était 4 juillet hier et du coup il est
remise de trophées j'ai rencontré
notamment alex de la chaîne french
cooking capacité 1 million d'abonnés ça
ça fait rêver mais c'est encore une
autre étape qui a rencontré plein de
monde j'ai rencontré nicole discute avec
un disque il ya des jérôme de la chaîne
now tech
j'ai rencontré cyprien très rapidement
fin aux jeunes créateurs et tous les
gens qui vous inspirent qu' on peut
regarder et il y avait une remise de
trophées où j'en rêvais gim uemoa et moi
il est quand je savais qu'il était la
maison est petite led de youtube
c'est vraiment félicitations pour ce
nombre record d'abonnés nous sommes
heureux de vous offrir ce trophée pour
récompenser vos efforts et rendre ce
moment encore plus exceptionnel
autre fait est vérifiée et emballé avec
soin par ic folklorique c'est se fait
aux états unis voilà bref donc ça c'est
chouette
et il ya un petit courrier alors
attendez avant de lire le courrier c'est
un la gueule quand même c'est dingue
c'est dingue parce que ce petit trophée
qu'ils ont changé les formats d'ailleurs
c'est vachement drôle
ces petits trophées il représente
tellement de travail tellement d'heures
on se rend pas forcément compte un
canton n'est pas créateur mais tellement
d'heures à bosser dur
moi je travaille du lundi au dimanche
wickens bon c'est un peu moi info 3 5
heures mais je bosse comme un [ __ ]
je suis peu chez moi je vois assez peu
ma famille et je m'en plaindre so lu
ment pas mais ce qui est ou c'est que du
coup le fait d'avoir ce trophée eh bien
ça cela matérialise un peu tout ça parce
que le fait de voir des des chiffres
augmentent et c'est génial mais là s'est
matérialisé voiliers et ça c'est cool ça
c'est vraiment génial
presented to me se re faire passer one
hundred thousand suns treiber est bien
chouette
merci youtube josh waters et le mettre
derrière il ira très bien avec une taque
je les aime bien son sont sympas c'est
ses trophées comme ça je trouve
peut-être même plus sympa que les autres
très joli surtout c'est le niveau argent
comme ça c'est chouette
donc c'est vraiment vraiment chouette et
s'est accompagnée d'un courrier j'en ai
marre de ce tabouret qui couine vraiment
je le change qui courent et youtube
alors je vous le dis on lit en même
temps votre chaîne compte cent mille
abonnés n'ont que très peu de créateurs
youtube pari d'atteindre d'ailleurs j'ai
appris un truc hier que en france en
suisse et france ou francophones
peut-être france jeu par avance et j'en
passe et le palier des 3 100 créateurs
qui ont plus d'un million d'abonnés
je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
mais je ne savais pas à ce point le
schiste c'est colossal 300 créateurs
plus d'un million d'abonnés en france
comme quoi
voyez il ya beaucoup de monde et ça
c'est plutôt chouette est la moins 100 à
plus de 100 milliards encore plus ce
n'est pas les chiffres
bref nous savons que les chiffres sur
youtube peuvent atteindre des sommets
j'aimerais mais nous espérons que vous
avez conscience de la réalité qui se
cache derrière ce nombre 2 0 les
internautes qui se sont abonnés à votre
chaîne ont été touchés par vos vidéos
elles les ont inspirés tonéo diverti
vous avez atteint ce nombre d'abonnés
grâce au travail
ce confirme votre persévérance et très
probablement votre humour contagieux
ça je ne sais pas pourquoi vous ne me le
dire que vous pouvez drôle parce que pas
une chaîne du monde
allez savoir défend démarrant votre
succès se doit d'être reconnue c'est
pourquoi nous souhaitons récompenser
l'ensemble de votre travail vous
fran ce trophée de créateurs argent gage
de notre estime de notre respect nous
savons que vous ne produire pas des
vidéos petites fautes de français
alors je vais le faire en français nous
savons que vous ne produisez pas des
vidéos pour recevoir des récompenses
c'est clair ce sont votre envie ce sont
vos envies
il ya peut-être quelques petites
corrections à faire mais selon le texte
donc ce sont vos envies de créer et
partager des contenus ainsi que les
spectateurs passionnés que vous avez su
rassembler qui vous pousse à le faire
nous sommes évidemment impatient de
découvrir à vos prochains contenus un
million d'abonnés peut vous sembler être
un objectif difficilement atteignable
pour le moment mais vous n'en est pas si
loin
vous pouvez compter sur nous pour vous
soutenir toutes nos félicitations
suzanne 6e youtube merci toute l'équipe
de youtube merci suzanne si je sais que
ces jeunes qui nous regardera jamais
cette vidéo merci quand même
je tiens à remercier tout
particulièrement justifiée match aller
le manager qui s'occupe de ma chaîne
avec beaucoup de talent merci justin
parce que en ayant passé les 100 mille
abonnés j'ai pu m'inscrire en un coup on
appelle ça c'est un accompagnement fait
de créateurs youtube je me suis inscrit
et du coup j'étais choisi donc ça c'est
cool et j'ai justin qui est basé à
londres qui a du coup s'occupe de la
chaîne me prodiguent des conseils me
permet d'avancer ils aillent dans le bon
sens donc c'est cool merci justin pour
tous cet accompagnement et puis j'espère
qu'on va m'aider encore plus à performer
chouette mais puis surtout ce trophée et
sans langue de bois aucune très
clairement ce trophée et bien c'est le
mien je suis très heureux de l'avoir
mais c'est aussi tout ça grâce à vous
parce que 100 personnes qui regardent
arrière et 100 personnes qui
s'intéressent 100 personnes qui vient en
tout cas chercher les infos sur la tête
et qu'il convient de découvrir et puis
peut-être sympa du coût du bateau à
s'abonner à ce mec derrière coule donc
c'est grâce à vous tous ça et j'en ai
pleinement conscience et je suis très
heureux et je sais qu'il met souvent
reproché de ne pas répondre à ces aux
commentaires et je le sais j'en ai
vraiment conscience et j'ai un vrai
problème là-dessus prennent de temps
fait mais j'ai en train de mettre des
trucs en place là pour le partir du mois
de septembre
explications dans quelques temps donc on
en reparlera plus tard pour justement
qu'on puisse mieux échanger façon plus
simple que moi je puisse échanger avec
vous vous puissiez échanger entre eux
aux fins d'ouvrir le tout qu'on n'en
parle plus tard sam est en tout cas
super cool
donc ça je tiens à vous remercier je
vous remercie énormément de faire
confiance de me suivre de me soutenir
dans mon travail
et moi je suis très heureux et très ému
et très touché d'avoir ce trophée
aujourd'hui qui est quand même je vous
dis une matérialisation de plein de
choses parce que je pense une femme plus
aux petits créateurs
ce qui est très dur sur youtube c'est
pas temps aujourd'hui mois 180 889 mille
abonnés il ya une certaine façon de
travailler qui s'est mise en place il ya
un procès ce qui existe dans mon choix
de sujets dont il est partenaire qu'elle
travaille sur la tête
mais le plus dur c'est de se lancer
c'est de partir du chaga 0 abonnés moi
j'ai créé ma fine en 2015 soit inscrit
sur youtube et j'ai commencé à faire mes
premières vidéos de blogs décembre 2016
ça devait être à fin décembre
j'ai fait des blogs est absolument nul
de chez nul d'ailleurs pouvait voir dans
mes premières vidéos ça n'a strictement
aucun sens mais j'avais une grosse envie
c'est un pote à moi mon pote arnaud là
qui va lancer deux nouvelles chaînes on
en reparlera aussi plus tard qui fait
des bisous qui me parlait beaucoup de
youtube
et puis je ne m'étais pas plus intéressé
que ça et j'ai regardé et j'ai acheté un
bouquin sur youtube
et quand j'ai découvert cuisinette stade
j'ai pris une tarte littérale dans ma
tronche et j'ai fait ah ouais ok et j'ai
comme beaucoup de monde et inspiré eu
envie de le faire et quand je regarde ce
que je faisais des lions et des zones
toujours très très loin c'est pas du
tout ça mais j'avais on est inspiré
c'était vraiment horrible que je faisais
et puis petit à petit je vais continuer
je me suis accroché j'ai fait des choses
par plaisir on dans l'est c'est un kiff
et puis je pensais pas du tout que ça
allait pouvoir fédérer du monde derrière
moi pour casseroles blog ses clacs si
j'avais continué ça n'aurait jamais
marché j'ai fait une vidéo sur les
rumeurs de l'iphone 8 qui a bien marché
qui aujourd'hui non mais
top 5 des meilleures vidéos de ma chaîne
et qui fait de me dire pourquoi est ce
que je pourrais pas lié ma deuxième
passion
enfin une de mes passions en tout cas
qu'est la tête et puis pourquoi pas en
parler sous forme de vidéos dont je les
fais on ne naît pas régulièrement temps
en temps un peu la rage
j'ai fait un petit hors série a était
2017 en parlant de stratégie youtube
parce que ça m'intéressait je pensais
que j'avais capté deux trois trucs et
puis histoire de communiquer puis de
filer un coup de main que je me crée à
tapas que tu aurais qu'en france y aller
mais pas trop de vidéos comme ça pour
aider un peu les jeunes créateurs
général beaucoup de chaînes américaines
pour comprendre comment ça marche et
l'algorithme des heures des heures des
heures des heures visionnage mange
beaucoup de contenu
et puis petit à petit ça augmente et me
rappelle lui le fait d'arriver aux 500
premiers à gagner du temps mais si
jamais y arriver ça avançait un abonné
deux abonnés fois c'était long le fait
d'arriver aux mille abonnés c'était
c'était exceptionnel je rappelle j'étais
comme un dingue mille abonnés et quand
on a un contenu qui débute une chaîne
qui en amorçage me l'a donné c'est
incroyable l'an 2000 abonnés se raconte
même pas 5000 abonnés c'est le graal
absolu 10000 abonnés rajoute 1 0 jeudi
c'est ouf
le jour où j'enregistre encore 1 0 ce
sera incroyable ce n'est pas si je serai
capable le jour ben la presse que si et
là aujourd'hui à presque 200 mille
abonnés bientôt où cet été mois d'août
normalement eh ben je rêverais de
rajouter 1 0 alors bon on verra on va
bosser pour et puis on va continuer
cette lutte continue et surtout à faire
à faire ce que j'aime et c'est ça qui
vous font en fait c'est si cette
difficulté
et puis après quand vous savez qu'on
vous a commencé vous avez passé les dix
mille a beau bien une certaine façon de
travailler une certaine méthode qui se
met en place
or il faut bosser énormément bossé bossé
bossé et donc je me rappelle c'est fin
2010 est donc allemand après avoir lancé
machel je me suis dit vous réfugier plus
loin dans la tête je continue je vais
plus loin plus de contenus flash publie
une vidéo par jour parce que je cite un
algorithme dernière je sais qu'il faut
pouvoir être découverts et pour pouvoir
être découvert il faut avoir beaucoup de
possibilités de découvertes soit vous
avez une vidéo qui marche énormément
comme l'a fait nicolas avec sa première
vidéo qui a cartonné qui la propulse
simple cent mille deux cent mille
abonnés en très peu de temps
c'était exceptionnel et bien soit vous
devez avoir plein de vidéos qui me
dégoûte mises bout-à-bout vous
permettent d'être découvert et c'est
justement ça qui est cool et et donc du
coup ben j'ai commencé à trouver un peu
mon process ma façon de travailler je
sais pas pourquoi j'ai ma tête je me
suis dit trente mille abonnés c'est un
sacré cap si j'arrive à passer les
trente mille abonnés il ya un truc qui
s'était même ça me paraissait tout impôt
inatteignable je réécoute mille abonnés
en faisant ma vidéo par jour tes débuts
2018 j'ai financé mon voyage à vegas
mais il faut que j'aille au csk sur les
événements je couvre le terrain avoue
avoir toutes les nouveautés touche en
place j'ai payé mon ses aises peillon
billet d'avion je suis parti aux états
unis je suis parti à new york première
fois aux us première fois vegas premiers
crs rencontré monde et où officie et
puis travailler j'ai commencé l'année en
effet quoi 12000 trop 10000 et 15000 à
bollène et 1018 et le jour de mon
anniversaire
dans la même année le 28 novembre 2010 8
passes et les cent mille abonnés avec
des potes qui étaient à la maison ça
fait un truc complètement ouf estime sa
représentée mais disons de couple ça
représente et mon anniversaire va
présenter en même temps et sans me l'a
volé tout seul
le même jour incroyable et voyez on est
quoi quelque chose comme 7 8 8 mois et
demi après quasiment à deux cent mille
abonnés et ouais c'est ces voix là c'est
juste derrière non je vous faire passer
un message à tous ceux qui sont
créateurs aujourd'hui à tous ceux qui se
lancent tous ceux qui auront envie de le
faire faut pas hésiter il faut y aller
le plus dur c'est de vous trouvez vous
c'est d'abord c'est la pompe c'est
commence à trouver un rythme une façon
de bosser un message vous différencier
fait des choses différentes soyez
différents soyez vous même proposé qui
vous êtes
ne cherchez pas à copier les autres chez
qu'on s'inspire toujours au début
inspirez-vous mais ne copiez pas trouvé
votre propre voix bosser bosser bosser
bosser bosser bosser bosser et encore
bosser vous arrêtez pas et le travail
paye la passion se transmet en étant
vous même en bossant énormément en
proposant des choses originales avec une
vraie valeur en étant sincère vous
pouvez toucher du monde et vous même
être touchés être surpris par ce qui
peut se passer
donc voilà je suis très heureux de
partager ça avec vous c'est quoi on est
à 15 minutes c'est un long monologue
mais voilà c'est très différent je
tenais vraiment à vous remercier de
cette vidéo fera pas d
des milliers de vues mais en tout cas
elle est là pour vous qui êtes présents
quasiment tous les jours merci merci
beaucoup merci à vous merci youtube et
c'est génial
à demain ciao